- All right, y'all, I'm
back with Olivia Munn
and Floor Is Lava host Rutledge Wood.
We're going to play a special version
of Rutledge's game show, right now.
This is called, what is it called?
Let's show your sign, show your sign.
- It's called Olavia!
- Olavia!
Get it?
(upbeat interlude)
All right, here's how it works.
Rutledge will read each
of us a trivia question,
one at a time.
If we get it right, we get a point.
But if Olivia or I get it wrong,
we have to take a shot of lava, or a sip,
AKA hot sauce that we have
here at our Zoom desks
and whoever gets the most points win, so.
And in honor of Olivia, and me
because I love superheros too,
all the trivia questions
are superhero theme.
So here we go.
Are you guys ready?
- (exhales) This feels so official.
Like that was absolute official game show.
That was so impressive.
- Ledge, I'm in it.
Okay,
- In it to win it.
- well you take it away, Rutledge.
This is Olavia.
Go.
- Here we go.
- Okay.
- Question one, this one's for Olivia.
Which film started off the current
Marvel superhero universe?
- Iron Man.
- Oh, that's correct!
She's on the board!
- Hey, Kelly, I'm just
gonna drink my water,
not the hot sauce.
(Kelly laughs)
- Oh, show off, okay.
- I love Olivia Munn! Okay.
- A little bit of a flex there.
Here we go, question to Kelly.
- Oh god.
- What weapon
does Thor carry?
- Oh, a hammer.
You know what?
I'm gonna take a little
bit of my milk, Olivia.
- Oh, wow.
- I'm lactose intolerant.
- Me too, mine's almond.
- [Olivia] Oh.
(laughs)
- Mine's oat.
- Yeah, Imma say say
y'all better get right
with Oatly, that stuff's amazing.
Here we go, question three.
Olivia, Olavia, how many actors
have played the role of
Peter Parker slash Spiderman
in the live action films?
- Toby Maguire, Andrew
Garfield, the new British kid.
He's British, right?
- Is that really important right now?
(laughs)
- You don't know how my mind works!
- Let's just assume
then, yes, he's British.
- Then there was, well
those are the first three,
but then there's more after that.
I'm gonna say live
actions, TV and everything.
It's gotta be more.
Let's say it's going to
be like 10 or 15 or 20
or 10 or 12.
- You are totally takin'
this hot sauce, chick.
- Three!
Drink up!
It was three.
- It was three?
- Yes, you had it
then you doubted yourself!
- You had it!
The thing I didn't know
he was tricking you on
if that new one, the animated one counted.
- Well, I didn't know if
he meant like back in the,
like in the olden days,
was there another one?
- I would've given you four,
but 15 is just, it's not,
that's not four's neighbor, okay, so.
- First of all, I love your
vat of hot sauce. (laughs)
- By the way, this came
from you, Kelly Clarkson.
- I know, I just, okay,
well I love that we sent you
the pandemic version, the
Costco version of hot sauce.
(Rutledge laughing)
We wanted you to not run out--
- We got this, we got this.
You guys sent me shot glasses.
- Drink up!
- Oh, wow.
- This comes out really slow.
Is this enough?
- You can literally
sip, 'cause I literally
have to sing after this. (chuckles)
I can't, I can't shot through this.
- Oh, you're fine.
(hollers)
Ooh, there it is!
Chase it!
- Oh, god.
- Kelly, are you ready?
- I'm ready.
Here we go, question number four.
How did the Fantastic Four
get their super powers?
- I'm gonna say, I mean, I've
seen kind of a poster for it.
So I'm gonna say from,
from the environment.
Something happened with the environment?
- Okay, okay, yes.
You've got something, that's very vague.
Can you roll that ball down
the hill a little more?
- Okay, that was a good guess, wow.
Something happened with the environment.
There was, there was,
there was an explosion.
- Could be, yes.
- Because of something,
and there were scientists testing stuff
and it got out and then it hits them
and then they were affected
and then they blew up.
- Let me check with the judges.
Olivia, do you buy most of that?
- I mean--
- I'm gonna say I have to sip this.
- Never having seen them,
I think that she did
a pretty good job and
I would give it to her.
I believe that they crashed back to earth?
- Cosmic or space radiation.
So really, you were there.
- Oh, I didn't get it!
I didn't get it!
- It was close, okay, all right.
I felt like you did.
You basically were like,
like there was a thing,
and then there was a
problem with it. (screams)
- That feels, that's integrity, Kelly
That's what you're feeling right now.
I appreciate it.
- Oh my god!
It's so spicy!
- You need a pickle back.
I'm gonna start a Nickelback cover band
with pickles called Pickleback.
- That means a lot.
- Oh my god, this is so hot!
- [Olivia] I know.
All right, Olivia, we only
got time for a couple more.
Here we go.
Which superhero does Bruce
Banner transform into?
- I know this one.
- 'Course you do.
'Cause you missed the last
one, you gotta know this one.
- (laughing) I know.
- No pressure, no pressure.
He was a, just assume
he was a tax accountant,
and then sometimes he got different.
- [Kelly] Really, just different.
- Turnt, as the kids say.
- I don't know why Bruce, Thor is--
- Bruce Banner, did you see the--
- Oh my god, no, I know!
It's Hulk!
- Yes!
- Ah, there we go!
- Because, I don't know why.
But, hey.
- I know, I took some milk
for you 'cause my mouth
is still on fire. (laughing)
- All right, Kelly, we're
gonna give you one last one.
Ooh, I'm gonna, I'm gonna pick.
What would Groot say if he
wanted to tell you he was hungry?
- Groot.
Exactly!
He would just say "groot,"
'cause that's all he says.
That's his one word.
- He'd say, "I am Groot."
- That's a great question!
- I love Guardians of the Galaxy!
I love them.
Anyway, that was awesome.
Olivia, well done!
My mouth is on fire still, so you win.
You guys are so awesome.
Thank you so much for playing!